[Aplausos]
[Música]
la pandemia del nuevo shark coronavirus
2 ha servido para que todos aprendamos
algo nuevo algunos han aprendido a hacer
pan casero otros hemos aprendido que
nunca se tiene suficiente papel
higiénico en casa los mercados
internacionales han aprendido otra cosa
que dependemos un montón de china
[Música]
el mundo necesita mascarillas china las
fabrica pero las ha estado acumulando
mientras china lidiaba con el
coronavirus guardo las mascarillas que
fabricaba ahora que otras naciones las
necesitan aumenta la presión sobre
beijing para reanudar las exportaciones
exacto después de décadas de
deslocalizar la producción nos hemos
encontrado con una escasez de
mascarillas en plena pandemia y que ha
pasado entonces pues que los chinos se
han puesto a trabajar a destajo en un
mes comparando abril con marzo china fue
capaz de multiplicar sus exportaciones
atentos por dos en los respiradores y
trajes de protección por seis de
mascarillas y por 25 de kits de
detección del coronavirus estamos
hablando de millones de toneladas de
material médico destinadas al mercado
internacional si es toda una hazaña en
lo que a manufactura se refiere
y os preguntaréis qué quiere decir todo
esto pues quiere decir que estamos
demasiado acostumbrados al made in china
la mayor parte de las empresas ni
siquiera se lo piensan dos veces cada
vez que montar una fábrica nueva china
es el lugar preferente y diréis porque
pues si en parte es porque china tiene
una mano de obra más barata pero no sólo
eso china también ofrece un montón de
ventajas tiene construidas las
infraestructuras necesarias para
exportar a todo el mundo y cualquiera
que quiera fabricar algo sabe que en
china puede encontrar buenos proveedores
y buenos fabricantes tras años de ser la
fábrica del mundo la mano de obra en
china está cada vez mejor formada
[Música]
dicho de otra forma imagina que quieres
construir una empresa de electrónica
pues lo mejor que puedes hacer es irte a
shenzhen ahí está todo encontrarás por
supuesto mano de obra más barata que en
eeuu pero es que además en shenzhen
tienes william bailey que es uno de los
mayores mercados de componentes
electrónicos del planeta tú vas allí y
dices literalmente hola buenas estoy
buscando esta placa controladora de
última generación para el drone que
quiero construir y en alguno de los
puestecitos encontrarás a un señor que
te venden placas de este tipo
prácticamente a kilos al terminar este
vídeo podéis buscar por internet
imágenes de gente yéndose a este
mercadillo y llevarse una bolsa de
microchips literalmente como si se
llevara un kilo de manzanas en pocos
lugares del planeta puedes hacer esto
así que es ya evidente china está hecha
para fabricantes
sí
pero claro cuando llegó una pandemia se
ven los inconvenientes de defender tanto
de china y esperad un momento porque las
empresas deben tener en cuenta otros
riesgos más allá de la pandemia hablamos
también de política como sabéis trump
inició una guerra comercial contra china
pero no os equivoquéis trump no es el
único que quiere dejar de hacer negocios
con beijing atentos a japón
[Música]
japón destina 243 mil 500 millones de
yenes para ayudar a las empresas a sacar
su producción fuera de china como veis
en el ambiente flota en ideas como que
la globalización estuvo muy bien en su
momento pero que ya no se puede confiar
en china y que hay que volver a producir
en cada país que ese mundo feliz donde
todos nos dábamos la manita
independientemente de nuestra raza
nuestra nacionalidad y nuestro credo y
cantábamos juntos el cumbayá se ha
terminado así que la pregunta de hoy es
de verdad lo ven así en el mundo
corporativo están las empresas pensando
en aislar a china de verdad estamos ante
el fin de la globalización hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la gran demanda china la primera vez que
se empezó a hablar de la globalización
fue en los años 90 y no precisamente
para bien porque los que tengáis más o
menos mi edad seguro que os acordáis del
movimiento antiglobalización organizaron
grandes protestas en seattle en fraga y
en génova pero y porque protestaban
sería más fácil deciros por qué no
protestaban pero así en resumen digamos
que esta gente pensaba que la
globalización serviría a los intereses
del malvado eeuu que el resto del mundo
se limitaría a proporcionar las materias
primas y la mano de obra barata para ser
explotada por las multinacionales
[Música]
validación es en sí misma una palabra
clave una máscara para no usar la
palabra capitalismo es un sistema en el
corazón de este sistema se encuentra en
los eeuu de américa el único imperio
existente en el mundo en la actualidad
táriq ali intelectual británico
paquistaní de esta forma eeuu se haría
aún más rico exportando sus productos y
su cultura por todo el mundo
llegaríamos a un punto en el que los
pueblos perderían su identidad por el
pérfido capitalismo y donde antes se
comían quemarse con la globalización
pasarían a comerse big macs
sin embargo lo que hemos visto en los
últimos años es todo lo contrario sí es
verdad
eeuu ha seguido creciendo y tiene un
peso enorme en la economía mundial pero
cada vez este peso es menor para que os
hagáis una idea en los años 80 eeuu
representaba alrededor del 25 por ciento
del pib mundial ahora en 2020 no llega
ni al 20% y esto es una buena noticia
porque significa que el resto del mundo
está creciendo de hecho podríamos decir
que el principal símbolo de la
globalización es el que va o se trata de
una comida típica del mundo árabe cuando
ya nací ni siquiera sabía lo que es un
kebab sin embargo ahora es una opción
gastronómica más junto con las pizzas
las hamburguesas el ceviche o el sushi
si no es globalización lo que está
haciendo por el mundo la franquicia es
procesar german donde el kebab ya me
diréis lo que es
[Música]
absolutamente brillante la firma de
glasgow que vende que va a buscar la
semana por valor de un millón de libras
pero vamos a centrarnos en el terreno
económico que ha pasado exactamente pues
si efectivamente las primeras empresas
que fueron a china iban atraídas por su
mano de obra barata pero por muchos
millones de chinos que haya a medida que
al país han llegado más y más empresas
las compañías han tenido que competir
por los trabajadores y todo esto
significa que los sueldos crecen crecer
hasta el punto de que desde hace ya tres
años estamos viendo noticias como estas
los niveles salariales de china
equivalen a superan los de partes de
europa esta es una tendencia que se
estaba viendo hace tiempo apple cerró su
última línea de producción en eeuu en
2004 para entonces la mayor parte de su
ensamblaje de productos se había mudado
a china sin embargo en 2013 ya habían
vuelto a fabricar ordenadores en texas
porque con los salarios a lanza más el
transporte desde el país asiático la
ventaja competitiva china frente a eeuu
era mucho menor que hace 20 años
y ya sé lo que estará pensando algunos
con el menudo planazo o sea que en
cuanto a los sueldos crecen en china-
las fábricas se van pues vaya política
de desarrollo de mía y quieres que te
diga fonseca pues no espérate porque lo
que ha pasado no es que las empresas se
vayan de china lo que ha pasado es que
las empresas se quedan porque ahora
china es un mercado es decir el objetivo
ya no es producir bienes en china para
exportarlos sino también para venderlos
en chino por ejemplo una empresa como el
ego ha conseguido sobrevivir a la crisis
del juguete tradicional y a la
competencia del videojuego gracias a sus
ventas en el mercado chino todo lo
perdido en occidente lo ha ganado en
china
[Música]
estamos hablando de un mercado de 1400
millones de personas que cada vez ganan
más dinero es decir que cada vez tienen
más yuanes para comprar sus productos y
claro que china sea un mercado ya es por
sí solo un incentivo para mantener las
fábricas en china por mucho que suban
los salarios de los trabajadores porque
pensadlo bien los costes de transporte
también son caros si tú tienes que mover
toneladas de tus productos en un barco a
través de un viaje transoceánico de
varias semanas como te puedes imaginar
eso cuesta una pasta pero si todo lo que
produzco en china lo puedo vender en
china me voy a ahorrar unos costes
logísticos
[Música]
eso ha provocado que muchas fábricas
permanezcan en territorio chino los
datos hablan por sí solos en 10 años
china ha pasado de exportar el 17 por
ciento de su producción total al 9 por
ciento la demanda en china ha crecido
tanto que ya sería viable montar una
fábrica en china solo para vender
productos en china pero no solo hablamos
de eso en los últimos 30 años la
tecnología ha evolucionado muchísimo es
decir cada vez las máquinas son mejores
y cada vez hacen más funciones de forma
automática
todo esto va a suponer un cambio
revolucionario para algunas industrias
lo hemos visto en muchos otros vídeos la
automatización la inteligencia
artificial y la impresión en 3-d
transformarán la fabricación intensiva
en mano de obra en fabricación intensiva
en capital todo esto quiere decir que
cada vez va a ser más interesante para
las empresas tener una fábrica moderna
con maquinaria de última generación
antes que una fábrica anticuada con
muchos trabajadores dicho de otra forma
el factor salarios ya no será tan
importante para decidir dónde situar una
fábrica es decir que llegados a este
punto a lo mejor lo que más me
interesaría es montar varias fábricas de
por ejemplo juguetes a nivel regional y
ahorro los gastos logísticos y si la
mano de obra es más cara la suple con
automatización ya no me interesa tanto
la mano de obra barata como tener a mi
disposición buenas infraestructuras
buenos proveedores energía barata y
trabajadores bien formados para manejar
la maquinaria
en visual políticos hemos hablado ya de
las impresoras 3d y la fabricación
aditiva para eso no vale cualquiera hay
que tener una formación especializada
así que estamos en definitiva ante una
tendencia que ya se estaba dando en los
últimos años la llamada regionalización
de la cadena de valor lo que produzco en
asia lo vendo en asia lo que produzco en
américa lo vendo en américa y lo que
produzco en europa se queda en europa
esta tendencia se ha acelerado como no
con la guerra comercial iniciada por
estados unidos la administración trump
ha hecho que tener una fábrica en china
para vender en eeuu tenga cada vez menos
sentido y en esas estábamos cuando ha
llegado el acontecimiento que
supuestamente lo cambia todo pero es que
no supuestamente es que lo cambia de
verdad ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
pero nano mix os voy a hacer una
pregunta y no vale mirarlo en la
wikipedia os suena el nombre de asml se
trata de una empresa neerlandesa de la
que seguramente no hayáis oído hablar en
vuestra vida pero es fundamental en el
mundo
dominan el mercado de la fabricación más
avanzada de chips a través del uso de
máquinas fotográficas que hacen
circuitos integrados ya lo sé no os
habéis enterado de nada pero no os
preocupéis quedaos con esto del trabajo
de asml dependen los principales
productores de chips del mundo la
estadounidense intel la surcoreana
samsung y la taiwanesa taiwán
semiconductor
así que estas compañías utilizan
componentes fabricados por asml para
hacer placas base placas base como la
que se encuentran en cualquier teléfono
así que si sin saberlo tú también tienes
muy cerca de ti un producto de asml y
ante esto nunca podemos olvidar el
llamado efecto mariposa
el aleteo de una mariposa en brasil
puede provocar un huracán en texas
edward lawrence matemático
estadounidense de esto va precisamente
la teoría del caos y de la
imprevisibilidad así que imaginad que
asml tiene que cerrar por cualquier
motivo imprevisto de repente se
hundirían las líneas de producción de
smartphones en todo el mundo aguantarían
mientras duraran los stocks pero
enseguida habría escasez de chips y por
tanto escasez de teléfonos móviles
pensáis que os estoy exagerando pues
nada de eso os voy a dar un ejemplo algo
parecido sucedió en el año 2012 en la
industria del automóvil se produjo un
incendio en alemania en una fábrica de
una empresa que se llama evonik evonik
es el principal suministrador mundial de
una resina esencial para los sistemas de
frenado en aquel momento las
consecuencias no tardaron en llegar
y entendió en una pequeña ciudad alemana
podría frenar la producción mundial de
automóviles que dados con este concepto
porque este año sí o sí vamos a tener
nos que familiarizar con el el concepto
de cadena de valor o también conocida
como supply chain hablamos de todo ese
proceso en el que están involucradas las
distintas empresas y proveedores
probablemente de varios países que
participan en la producción de un bien y
como comentábamos antes si es verdad la
supply chains cada vez son más globales
pero todavía no podemos hablar de una
globalización al cien por cien me
explico en realidad de lo que estamos
hablando es de que ahora mismo en el
mundo comercial eeuu europa y china
podemos sumarle si queréis japón los
tigres asiáticos rusia algún país
latinoamericano y para de contar
[Música]
quizás alguno piense que algún otro país
asiático tipo malasia o indonesia
también está en el mercado internacional
pero sus cifras aún son muy reducidas la
supply en global depende excesivamente
de china a unos niveles que
probablemente no os imagináis por
ejemplo el 95 por ciento del ibuprofeno
que consume eeuu llega de china
el coronavirus podría causar escasez
mundial de medicamentos a medida que los
cierres de fábricas de china golpean a
las cadenas de suministro y como os
podéis imaginar esta dependencia de
china es un problema porque la cadena de
suministro se vuelve muy frágil es decir
basta con que pase algo como la
imposición de aranceles por parte de
trampa al acero chino para que las
supply chains de muchas industrias se
vengan abajo pero cuando más visibles y
ha hecho este riesgo ha sido como os
podéis imaginar con la crisis de el
coronavirus de la noche a la mañana
media china se puso en cuarentena y eso
significado el cierre temporal de un
montón de fábricas algunas han tenido
problemas porque estaban acostumbradas
al buen hacer de china este buen hacer
les permitía trabajar con la filosofía
just-in-time para reducir gastos
y diréis qué es esto del just in time
pues os lo explico gestionar un gran
almacén es más caro que si recibes los
productos e inmediatamente los
distribuyen a las tiendas just-in-time
justo a tiempo es decir reducimos los
gastos de inventario al máximo el
objetivo es tener la cantidad exacta de
productos en el lugar justo y en el
momento adecuado por eso cualquier
cierre de fábricas durante semanas puede
provocar un montón de problemas en la
cadena de suministro
[Música]
la crisis de coronavirus también ha
servido para demostrar que empresas han
podido sobrevivir mejor al okda un chino
lo que han intentado algunas compañías
es compensar el cierre aumentando la
producción en sus fábricas en países
como vietnam
[Música]
mattel ha trasladado parte de la
fabricación de ir botes pro de china
vietnam como veis gracias a tener
fábricas en vietnam es decir fuera de
china algunas empresas han podido seguir
produciendo pese al confinamiento chino
así que han marcado un gol por toda la
escuadra a sus competidores en el mundo
empresarial han tomado buena nota de
esto y han llegado a una conclusión el
concepto de china 1 es decir vale mantén
tu factoría en china produce para
conseguir los yuanes de esos 1.400
millones de chinos pero además intenta
establecer te en otro sitio para
protegerte de cualquier imprevisto
por lo tanto las empresas no se están
yendo de china simplemente están
diversificando con fábricas en otras
ubicaciones y qué efecto tiene esto
sobre la globalización pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver una auténtica
globalización podríamos decir que la
globalización 1.0 arrancó cuando eeuu
puso en marcha el plan marshall europa
occidental había quedado muy debilitada
con la destrucción de la segunda guerra
mundial ayudando a europa a salir del
agujero eeuu conseguía un socio
comercial de primera y así ha sido hasta
nuestros días de asia llegaría a la
versión 2.0 de la globalización que es
cuando japón y los tigres asiáticos
empiezan a llenar el mercado mundial con
sus productos cuando éramos niños si os
acordáis todo era made in taiwan o made
in japan pero es que estos países no
sólo han sido productores sino que
también han sido importantes
consumidores de productos europeos y
estadounidenses
la globalización 3.0 es lo que hemos
visto en los últimos años ese giro hacia
el comercio con china
[Música]
ahora estamos viendo ese momento en el
que china se ha convertido ya en la
fábrica del mundo y que ha evolucionado
para que ahora hablemos del gran mercado
del mundo ya no sólo hablamos de china
como un sitio para fabricar sino de
china como un sitio para vender y cuál
es el siguiente paso de la globalización
pues expandirse hasta otros países y ya
se están dando pasos para ello os hemos
hablado ya de cómo apple ha ampliado su
producción en vietnam pero noticias así
ya no son asuntos puntuales sino
tendencia por ejemplo mirad lo que
anuncia la taiwanesa hon hai más
conocida por su nombre comercial
foxconn que es nada menos que el
principal ensamblador del iphone y de la
nintendo switch desde sus 12 fábricas en
chino
y expande sus operaciones en india y
vietnam en medio de tensiones
comerciales pero las cosas van mucho más
allá de la guerra comercial o del
coronavirus china va a jugar un papel
protagonista en esta nueva fase de la
globalización en esta expansión de la
globalización a otros países hay sitios
que ya se están convirtiendo en algo así
como las chinas de china es decir
lugares a los que las empresas chinas
están externalizando su producción esto
va a hacer que china amplíe sus lazos
comerciales con países que también se
van a beneficiar de esta situación y si
por supuesto hablamos de vietnam de
camboya de laos bangladesh y filipinas
pero también de otros países mucho más
alejados de beijing
[Música]
está convirtiendo a etiopía en una
fábrica gigante de fast fashion pero no
es solo que las empresas chinas estén
encontrando nuevos lugares en los que
situar sus fábricas o propiciando que en
otros países aparezcan empresas a las
que les están vendiendo maquinaria para
impulsar su producción es que china
también está encontrando mercados para
firmas que tienen mucha competencia en
casa este es el caso del fabricante de
smartphones transition
[Música]
el mayor vendedor de teléfonos en áfrica
es una compañía china poco conocida al
principio de este vídeo os contábamos
como políticos como donald trump o
shinzo abe están presionando a las
empresas a irse de china lo que está
pasando es que algunas sí que podrían
marcharse pero todo apunta a que la
mayor parte está apostando por quedarse
en china y optar por esta estrategia de
la que hablábamos antes la estrategia de
china más uno para llegar a otros
mercados así que parece que los cambios
del coronavirus no son tantos o al menos
no son tan dramáticos como esperábamos
hablamos de una globalización aún más
expansiva regionalización de la cadena
de valor y la estrategia china +1 estas
son las tres tendencias que estamos
viendo mucho más allá del fin de la
globalización
pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que esta nueva fase de la
globalización hará que todos los
africanos terminen comiendo noodles
pensáis que puede llegar el momento de
latinoamérica y lo que es más importante
os gustan más las hamburguesas o los
kebabs podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y mientras tanto no
olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto